hey you know what uh honors was a great
night last night the stars were out it
was a total los angeles night but no one
was more los angeles than the only guy
that i saw who showed up in sunglasses
and wore them indoors the entire time
and he is the all-pro tight end and
friend of the program courtesy of our
friends at courtyard by marriage all
right travis kelsey how are you travis
rich how you doing big guy how you doing
man i wish i was playing this dang on
game man
i'll tell but it's uh this one stings
but uh i would
i would say that i am enjoying myself
last night was absolutely amazing how
can you not root for a guy like
whitworth right and uh and what he's
done in the community i mean he just
motivated me to go and
lend a helping hand to anybody everybody
and everybody was it was a special night
last night i love it man it was it was a
great night and and i greatly appreciate
you calling in as always but i'm sorry i
just got to dial it back a little bit
what was with the shades all night
travis what was with the shades oh you
know you got to keep it cool the lights
were bright last night rich
what i mean uh the lights were bright uh
even indoors even indoors
the front row are you kidding me you got
the lights right in your face that's
right you got to make sure okay take
care of the eyes no i'm i'm always
focused on you know where i am uh in a
promo photograph you know whether i'm in
the center of it you know for
whatever tv shows i'm doing with all my
other colleagues and
i'm very you know always aware of where
i'm seated say at an event like this
notice you had a better seat than your
brother last night uh travis even though
you're both situated very well did you
say anything to your brother when you
turned around and said hello to him
travis i was confused on why they put
the other 87 right next to him
uh he sat right next to rob ground
crossing i was just like why wouldn't
they just switch me and rob and
put me next to my brother because that's
the real reason why i was there is my
brother was up for the walter paid man
of the year award for the philadelphia
eagles so i was
confused on that but i'll tell you what
i'll take a front row seat any time
you're gonna hand them out i'll take
them
so you're sitting in front of rob
gronkowski for crying out loud and again
i don't want to start anything even
though i really am uh the watts sat next
to each other the watts set right next
to each other they did that for them and
we got a we got to fight for the
kelsey's brother we gotta do it i gotta
we gotta i gotta talk to the nfl about
this seating situation it's unacceptable
absolutely unacceptable absolutely
totally unacceptable i agree well at any
rate man um okay now that we've gotten
that out of the way i just wanted to
stir things up that's the only thing i'd
like to do here
so you you know you mentioned uh you
wish you were playing in this game that
just said though you are from ohio
you are a cincinnati bear cat have you
heard from back home about how happy
people are even though it your misery
kind of added to their enjoyment travis
yes and that's probably the hardest
thing is uh is talking to all my friends
and family my teammates from cincinnati
um all the people that i've i've you
know still keep in contact with um i'm
trying to i'm trying to enjoy rooting
for them um but it's uh it's tough it's
tough it's you know hats off to the
bengals for how they how they persevered
through the entire playoffs really i
mean finding ways to win in the second
half but um the way we lost i i really
feel like we uh we gave it to him um and
that's just i mean that's my personal
opinion man that one hurt well i know
and then of course uh you were on the
business end of a keegan michael key uh
one-liner about the second half of
football
last night yeah i almost i almost booed
him i'm a big fan of it no i understand
that he almost got he almost got a real
loud boo right when he uh said that joke
i know that i kept it i kept it cordial
i didn't want to go out of line
understood um
and i just uh he also kind of
i don't know if you knew this but he's a
big chargers fan
and um he was at the game during the
season where you know i called game in
overtime so i i think he was uh i think
he's still i want to say a little butt
hurt but he
might be feeling a little butthurt
about that one so he had to take a shot
you did call the game with a whole
boatload of yak man that's no question
about that um so uh what did so then
what is your answer what to the question
that has been asked quite a bit over the
last weeks like what did happen
um in that game did it all start with
the way the first half ended travis do
you think um
no so i they made second half
adjustments that uh and we needed to to
make plays you know they have a great d
they have a great defense they really do
they play well together they have a
stout front uh they're secondary makes
plays when the ball's in the air um and
punches punch the ball out when they can
um then it's just you know hats off to
the bengals it's they made second half
adjustments and we got to be able to be
better in those situations i personally
think that
i got a little uncharacteristic
myself i
i had a drop here and there i kind of
elaborated on a few routes that might
have you know
screwed up some timing or stuff some
things but i uh i think that when when
we have had those moments of uh of
struggling uh to get the ball down the
field i've i've tried to do too much and
uh that's where i'm at the biggest thing
for me is always looking at the guy in
the mirror and trying to find a way to
to
to will my team to win the next time and
so i'm always self-evaluating i just i
just i wish i was doing better for my
guys well i mean you you know what uh
super bowl is and playing in one and
winning in one and uh also know the hype
involved uh i'm sure you're hearing it
that if borrow and the bengals win this
one then perhaps uh this is a bengals
conference and that the torch has been
passed from you today what do you say to
that i i would say that uh they won the
afc so it's their conference to to win
to lose next year um you know that
that's the reality of it and i got to
eat that for for breakfast every day
until next year and how do you consume
such breakfast travis how do you consume
that
you just eat it as fast as you can rich
you just eat it as fast as you can uh
you're trying to figure out you know
what's gonna make this breakfast taste
better and uh from there you know what i
mean hopefully we're making pancakes and
french toast next season well it sounds
like it sounds like you are eating this
breakfast and serving up a side of
underdog that uh you know that that
you're no longer the favorites because
um you will wear that and pressure's off
and you got the house money now
now they don't reality it's reality rich
you gotta you gotta get the tip your hat
when you when you when you can man
so you're just setting up a narrative
that you're gonna just wanna jam through
to everybody i'm coming back with a
vengeance
like a liam neeson movie well that
sounds like travis kelsey and uh what is
that taken
it was taken it was taken from there the
championship was taken
i will find you
[Laughter]
this is travis kelsey here on the rich
eisen show all right so you are
partnering with my friends at courtyard
by marriott for the sleepover right
that's where people are the official
hotel of the nfl sir and uh and i'm i'm
excited to be sharing some spotlight on
what they're doing with sofi stadium
they're a super bowl uh sleepover
contest that is a super fan is going to
get a chance to win the night before the
super bowl uh
so the courtyard marriott turned a suite
in selfie stadium into a hotel room
looking at you we're looking at you on
that king-sized bed having a good time
with your shoes on travis first belly
flop on that one
i'll tell you if you've ever laid in a
courtyard marriott ben that's a one
right there i'll tell you what you get
some good sleep in that one and then you
get to throw the curtains back and see
so far looking beautiful and all done up
for the super bowl the biggest stage in
the world uh the experience you only get
with with courtyard marriott wow
do you know who's the one who's gonna be
i i don't know if i should say this i'm
telling any tells that at school you
know who's checking those people in this
weekend do you know that i don't know i
don't know well let me tell you it's a
good question i don't know where the
front desk is i'll tell you who that
person is
i don't know if they even got a bellman
you're talking to that person travis i'm
interested in what they're going to do
about the shower situation well
i'm i'm honest you have big things they
have huge things
showers that you're having and cleaning
it up or what are we doing well i'll
tell you uh since i'm the one checking
them in travis you're talking to that
guy maybe it's oh yes maybe hold on a
minute wait for it wait for it maybe
it's a gatorade shower right you know
what i'm saying it's the super bowl
after like it yeah i like it what color
is the gatorade because i want to go oh
stop you're like it's crazy
like
this man alone he's an nfl employee of
the chiefs man leave him alone
sorry
leave him alone
[Laughter]
all right what are you doing this season
what are you doing the off season what
are you on
um what do you got
now focus on uh trying to
get out of the gates earlier or faster
this year
than this past season obviously we kind
of stumbled uh coming out the gates uh
this year after a big win uh you know
just trying to
reevaluate myself every single year year
and you're out always trying to get
better rates i think a lot of fun you
always see me all over the place
traveling playing golf that's right i'm
so i'll be honest with you i'm i'm
doing all of that but at the same time i
i got a determined mindset to come out
you know what i know you're focused and
you've got
you know you've got your your career
trajectory taking you back to the state
of ohio and i don't mean uh to play
football i mean for you to actually be
enshrined um i can say those things
don't worry about it but i i'm more
interested in the kelsey aspect of it
many people are travis kelsey not many
people uh run like you run figuratively
nobody can wear shades like that nobody
can shave off a beard and have people
pissed off that they do that i want the
off-season travis kelsey plans what do
you got where are you going what are you
doing i know one thing i'm keeping beard
i'm not getting rid of this thing i
learned that's that regard
i'm not just going to get some flames on
social media again okay uh that's number
but i i will say
that we're going to have a lot of fun
you might see me on the tube a little
bit more with a microphone in my hand
oh like what do you mean what do you got
uh
i've always had fun
you know acting like a commentator in
the living room mocking everybody for
the most part but uh i think you know
that's a that's something after football
that i would enjoy doing i've seen i've
seen a lot of guys transition into that
world yes um and i think it's about time
i start to really you know just don't
speak
so you might see a little bit of me here
and there uh with the microphone in my
head what are you doing like for for
okay because now i'm thinking
uh it's not it's not fully based
together yet so i don't want to spill
the beans but i'll tell you what i do
know exactly how i'll have to jump back
on this is my lane no no this is my lane
now okay
this is my lane you're you're talking my
world i'll never be i can never be rich
no i'm not here in your footsteps i mean
i'm not i'm not feeling the entire 90s
of just the sports world that was
michael jordan wayne gretzky yeah just
the the icons that i mean you made
watching sports and and and listening to
sports fun for kids like me to wear i
just i feed it man i've seen it so i'm
not i'm not looking to try and be the
natural secretary no no that's
close to impossible well travis i'm
looking to have some fun travis you're
awesome you know how i feel about you
you could take the close to out of it
it's impossible you can't be me so let's
just put it let's be honest here so i
love it okay i love it i speak things
into existence okay so um look uh so are
you talking sports is that what you're
talking about or entertainment do we
even hear entertainment uh what do you
think i'm trying to figure out exactly
what it what that is you know i
grew up loving game shows uh
i grew up
appreciating uh commentating in the in
different sports okay um so i'm not sure
what exactly it looks like i'm just i
just want to become more experienced in
it okay i mean i know it's a different
world for me um and i just yeah i'm kind
of unaware and i just want to be more
aware about it well you have my number
if you have any thoughts prop you know
questions or whatever
you know um the watts did not reach out
to me before they did their tag and they
got canceled after one year so that's
that is that is
that is a cautionary tale okay
i'm here for you i'm a resource
certainly if you're going to give away
cash and prizes my god i will watch that
show
all right i will watch that show um
you know you know i'm gonna be hitting
you up now okay
i'm serious like please do absolutely
please do please do i appreciate you
brother all right right back at you go
ahead and do whatever else you're doing
and um and uh thank you for partnering
up with courtyard by marriott it's an
incredible event the winner of the
contest is from chicago hey now chad
vincent's going to be the one staying
overnight
the bears that's it okay very good well
the bears are now in the super bowl
there you go
they made it there you go stadium
fantastic you take care of travis i hope
to run into you you'll be welcome
seriously reach out to me reach out to
me you know it rich okay you know it
take care travis kelsey everybody right
here
dude is he gonna do a game show is he
gonna do something
i don't know del tufo thinks he's gonna
you know do something oh you already
know which means it's for fox
no i'm just i'm
trying to cover your tracks now i'm not
covering my tracks i'm just saying i
think i might
you might know i'm i guess then i think
i'm right what is it
what do you think why can't you say
football league starting in a couple
weeks
well spring football playing football
fox usa usfl okay so that is funny
perfect way to say it it's fox and nbc
but i mean it could be well travis
kelsey would definitely get me
interested in hearing what he sounds
like
i can totally see him getting into that
he's in the office perfect time in the
offseason what is that yeah april to
july
and he'd be great in a booth
he'd be amazing fantastic plus he can
help scout talent for the team that's
just a guess you know sometimes
out there you know he could do that i
would be i think he'd be great he'd be
great you'd be a lot of fun hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here